a perfect start to the year for
beachgoers and lovers of outdoor sports
record temperatures in the uk made this
the warmest new year's day since 1916.
but that signals bad news for anyone
fond of ice skating this rink in london
closed because the ice had started to
thaw
at st james's park it's starting to feel
like spring what month of the year does
this feel like
i'm going to say probably march just
warming up yeah it's really unusual for
the first of january
probably like autumn like september
october
it's like september yeah maybe like late
september temperatures here went right
up to 16.3 degrees celsius londoners
enjoyed it but not without guilt oh it's
lovely yeah it was very nice feel bad
you know greto probably tell us off but
um this is obviously quite enjoyable
guiltily enjoying it knowing it's
because of climate change the met office
is warning that this warm weather will
be short-lived with temperatures due to
plunge in the coming days daytime
temperatures down to 3 degrees in
edinburgh by tuesday and to 7 degrees in
cardiff and here in london
the unusually warm weather is being
caused by warm subtropical air from the
azores but is expected to turn more
chilly across the country next week with
arctic winds overnight frost and even
some snow temperatures are above the
seasonal average in italy and france too
in spain the weather is being described
as abnormal so we're sort of nearly
double what we'd kind of expect for this
time of year it's unprecedented really
in in that sense it's a very warm a warm
spell with just days to go to enjoy a
bit of warmth here in the uk
this bank holiday weekend may best be
spent outdoors
sadia chowdhury sky news